on savait qu'à la boîte à puch a demandé
au public pour gaver sur vous hockey et
j'ai deux trois trucs qui m'ont petit
peu laisser chacun à vos chafouine et
aller carrément mêmes shampouiner
d'actions déjà ya quelqu'un du public
non wrestler et cela reste aulas resto
la non mais non non non non non non
reste là restera comme ça il ya
quelqu'un qui nous a dit on voit
toujours l'arrêt de doc gynéco quand on
est derrière lui ça perturbe les
canibulles et qui a dit ça on peut
vérifier n'a aujourd'hui live est maire
il a calé minerai à vous avez l'air déçu
les filles alors la gare près de rennes
sous ses vêtements il est vrai que si je
peux tout cas en vous il ya beaucoup
d'humour gary kelly n'arrête pas de
chanter pendant les pubs c'est
insupportable tiens dit ça alors là non
ils ont fait brûler votre question non
ils n'ont pas dit insupportable s'est
pas pressé sinon mais c'est une place
pour tout le monde vous le dira mon
manon voici à mais pour moi c'est un
enfer vous annoncez film d'amour vous
vous êtes pas conscient de ce que vous
venez de faire parce que moi la semaine
dernière j'ai fait ma première émission
etc et des âmes a dit que le plus
important pour elle c'est elle est posée
à l'hyper blessés bah écoute les bases
si vous êtes blessé mais terne urgo et
enfin contribuer à
le vrai c'est grave quand on me dit tu
dois bing là ce qu'il ya sur ce sur ce
sursaut bristol un format a2 connaissez
à 12 sur ne serait pas je ne suis sûr de
rien aujourd'hui
il est 20 heures 16 cents en direct je
vous dire ce qu'a dit le public sur les
chroniqueurs
aucun chroniqueur ne reste à la fin de
l'émission pour parler au public
contrairement à ces récits rihanna alors
je vous dire vous connaissez mon
écriture pas du tout ça
alors qu'est ce que vous avez à dire là
ce qu'on peut se défendre
non mais pas vous défendre c'est
inadmissible
voilà non mais vous aux façons venant
vous êtes seul qui restait le plus vous
ce que vous mettez beaucoup de temps
pour partir de vous et des thunes échos
qui croit qu'une heure après l'émission
et il a dirigé vers 23h et un tabac
voilà donc alors je vous le dire tirez
vous ne dites pas en voir au public
on ne le dit jamais assez rigide un
ordre de ne pas parler aux chroniqueurs
dont on n'a pas droit de leur parler en
revanche dehors quand on vous le dit à
partir de maintenant vous allez dire au
revoir
je vous le dis et ce sera comme ça tous
les soirs très bien vous le dit non mais
c'est bon merci quelque chose non on dit
au revoir mais c'est vrai qu'on a une
vie de famille aussi confrontons partie
siennes leur mire l'arrivée de 0,1 calé
au fond sont presque couché on est sûr
de l'emporter à la 43e un connard
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est bon ils sont fous cela oui ou
alors tu chose que je peux faire quelque
chose je ne viens pas de légumes
aucun des légumes il ya quelques années
quand on élève toutes les feuilles reste
un coeur qu'on peut tremper dans la
vinaigrette et croquer tk vol paris
combien de fois j'ai pas fait gaffe à
pas de pouls de la branche sur la gueule
soit le public qui vient et on va être
très très honnête aussi et on a déjà vu
ailleurs quand t'es pas là ils sont
douze le public qui vient c'est pour te
voir et c'est wasquehal micro à la fin
je pense qu'ils s'en tape un petit peu
et je maintiens mes s'essayer toutefois
pas du tout à qui veut l'entendre qu'ils
veulent pas voir leur famille là et
alors et voilà une orange foot d'avoir
[Applaudissements]